having
run an abortion service for
17 years
there are very very few women who will
come back and basically say
i really wish i hadn't done that the
number of women who contact us and say
thank you
for
enabling me to
put my life back on track
is huge
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissing
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guest today is the
former chief executive of the british
pregnancy advisory service anne farady
the problem we have with this episode is
we lost the footage we had from the main
camera we already fired our producer for
the hundredth time hasn't helped so in
this episode everything is as normal but
the only thing is you won't see us front
on which i'm sure will be a relief
i'm ferretti welcome to trigonometry
thank you very much for having me it's
great to have you on uh you know that we
interviewed dr callum miller recently uh
who has a very different position to you
on abortion i think it's fair to say i
think it's fair to say he does
and we had a long discussion where we
were kind of probing some of his
arguments and at the end of it in fact
at the beginning i said this is our
first foray into this we're going to get
someone on who has a different view
and at the end of it he actually said
well i can recommend you some people who
who disagree with me vehemently but who
are very good and you were right at the
top of that list so welcome to the show
thank you very much indeed great to have
you on tell everybody who are you how
are you where you are what has been your
journey through life that leads you to
be sitting here talking to us oh my god
um right so this is going to be a very
short very short account of who i am and
where i am
so
um i'm actually a journalist
way back in the day
um who
got very interested in women's
reproductive health
through doing medical writing
ended up working for the family planning
association
running their press office
doing parliamentary advocacy work around
abortion right the way back in the early
90s is probably about before you guys
were born
when actually abortion was very charity
yeah she is no no but you know abortion
was way more controversial than it is
now and
at that time the campaigning was
largely about a lot of it was about
funding in the nhs because about half of
women had to pay
for their own procedure
because it wasn't really seen as
something that women should be able to
get on the nhs
and i went from there to running what
was the
turned out well ended up being the
largest abortion provider in britain
with a
good advocacy department to make sure
the
politicians and the public understood
why women needed abortions
and um i always used to describe it as
the best job in the world but
i was decided that i would uh
finish work when i got to 60. so i'm now
focusing on writing
i've gone back and studied philosophy at
university i'm doing a lot of dog
walking and
some talking to guys like you yeah well
it's a pleasure to have you on so let's
get straight into it uh the
i pushed back on callum quite a bit
but i also agreed with quite a lot of
what he said i think his callum's main
argument from memory was essentially
that
our job as people is to protect the most
vulnerable people in society and unborn
children are that
that is a life and taking it is immoral
and wrong what say you to that
well um
funnily enough there are a lot of areas
that callum and i would agree on
um
and i do think that
abortion is
taking a life
of thoughts
but the one thing that i think is
profoundly immoral
is
um
forcing a woman
to carry a pregnancy and have a child
when she
really does not want to do that and i
also think it's profoundly immoral to
force a woman to have an abortion
if she wants to have a child and i think
that these are
the whole thing about
how you deal with your pregnancy
and what kind of family you have
is something that is
deeply
it's a deeply intimate moral
consideration
that should be made by the person
who is going to
live the life of responsibility for it
and you can have an opinion on it i can
have an opinion on it callum can have an
opinion on it but at the end of the day
is the woman who is pregnant who is
going to
look at herself every day in the mirror
knowing the decision she made about that
pregnancy
and i think that she should be
responsible
for it and to do that she has to be able
to choose
and why is abortion special and because
um you know based on what you've said to
going with the logic of your own
argument if abortion is killing
in what other area
would we allow people to make a decision
for themselves that allows them to kill
someone else for their own benefit
whatever however important that benefit
is i
yeah and
there are no other
areas
in which we would do that which is why
when people say oh women um can have
abortions
just because
it's an it's inconvenient to have a
child a completely wrong i mean we
wouldn't allow people to
bump off their parents would they
because it's inconvenient to be caring
for your elderly parents
but pregnancy is utterly different you
know when when a woman is pregnant
the the the life that we're talking
about here is actually growing inside
her
it's something that's going on within
her actual
body
no one else can intervene
in
to affect that life
without interfering or intervening in
her life once she's given birth
that's obviously entirely different
teams of
social workers and nurses and whatever
can be
you know doing stuff for that baby but
up until that moment
[Music]
it you know she is the person who's
affected and i think it
it's curious that we lose track of that
we kind of lose sight of it so
if you think about it people will say oh
well
you know
surely
it's okay to
um
insist
that a woman should go on with the
pregnancy at least until the child's
born because it's a human life
but you know
you wouldn't say
to
you wouldn't say to me
you have to
give your kidney
to
keep somebody alive
or you have to make a blood donation
to keep another person alive because
that way you know forcing people to do
things with their own bodies
for other people
i think that really is the road to hell
you know these things are seen as being
voluntary and i think
however much it bothers us
i think we have to see
abortion as being the choice of the
person who's
living the life
you know we talk about
we talk about
when does
life begin or become morally significant
in in the womb
[Music]
but you have to remember
the at no point does a woman become
morally less significant
or morally less of a person because
she's pregnant so why would we
take away her rights to deal with her
own body
in a way that we wouldn't do beforehand
that's you know that's the way the
i kind of reckon it and that doesn't
mean
you know
it
it it doesn't mean that
i
have got some great love
of abortion as a procedure actually i've
got a great
a great presumption in favor of life i
think having a child is wonderful
but i've got a great love of people's
individual freedom
and i think that
you know
having a child is something that
we have to give people freedom to decide
about
i couldn't agree with you more on the
liberty about your own body and just
touching back on cobit that argument
became deeply unfashionable when we were
talking about mandatory vaccinations
well it it is something that is
deeply unfashionable in fact one of uh
but but it's also it's particularly
unfashionable when it comes to this
because
it amazes me that you know you have
organizations like um
the alliance for democracy and freedom
and so on who are absolutely fantastic
on a whole load of freedom and democracy
issues but when it comes to this freedom
of a woman to decide
about her own body
suddenly all of that goes a bit out of
the window
and
i
i think
or the other thing that happens
is that people think that abortion
is is some kind of an identity issue
it's like a feminist
issue
um
that is about how
women define who they are
and i don't think that
that's right at all i think the
you know nobody
wants to identify
as a woman who
has had an abortion
um
you don't
support a woman's right you don't you
don't exercise your right to abortion
let's put it like this you don't
exercise that right like you exercise
your right to vote
you know oh i'm a woman abortion's
illegal i think i'll have one of those
that's not you know that is never the
way it works on an individual level
abortion is the solution to a particular
problem you had sex you got pregnant you
really do not want to have a baby
but
you know it it's got such a kind of
political ramifications moral
ramifications for the people that the
whole thing becomes
you know a real mess and my sense is
you know
can we please leave people
to make these deeply intimate decisions
for themselves
and let them take the responsibility for
it
because
ultimately it's
it's her body and we live in a society
that generally now
recognizes that
people
should do that
but hang on a second so
on the whole i agree with the argument
but shouldn't there be limits around
when a woman should be able to get
abortion or she could be able to get an
abortion because for instance eight
months in i mean a baby most babies can
live outside of the womb eight months in
should that be allowed
okay well uh so this was one of the
things that
used to
really um
do my head in actually
when i was running b-pass
um
because
we have a
24-week time limit
and
i think in lots of ways
we could probably
say that it's not unreasonable
you know
24 weeks is
six months we can accept that
by then
frankly
very very very few women
would be contemplating having an
abortion because
by that time you can feel fetal movement
you're generally
you know visibly pregnant
in this country it's quite easy
to get an abortion
in early pregnancy
um
what is a terrible thing
i believe
is
when you have that guillotine of dates
and so the and and believe me this is an
this is a seriously practical problem
where there will be all kinds of reasons
why a woman will present late in
pregnancy and sometimes it's got to do
with the fact that
a wanted pregnancy has become
an unwanted pregnancy
maybe
um it's because her circumstances have
changed maybe her relationship has
broken down
um
you know there are a whole load of
things that can go on pregnancy always
happens within the context of a woman's
life
but it seems to me utterly insane
the an abortion that is perfectly legal
on the thursday when she is 23 weeks
and six days pregnant
is utterly illegal
on the friday
so
say the doctor's sick
um
say
something happens like there's a train
strike and she can't get to the clinic
if you've got that absolute guillotine
of a time limit
it's not like
it you know it's not like a speeding
limit where oh you can go a little bit
beyond it it's literally the case that
one minute past midnight
a pregnancy that was legal now isn't and
that to me
is
mind-numbingly
stupid
and it's very harsh
for women who are
on that cusp and then when it comes to
the very late abortions those ones that
i think make everybody
draw in a deep breath you know it's when
you hear
of women and this can really only happen
for severe fetal anomaly
and you hear of these very very late
cases and typically
that will have been
a managed situation between a woman
and her
doctor
and
very often those very late ones
are when the baby would be born with
some absolutely crippling
anomaly that means that it couldn't be
kept alive after birth
and the woman has
said to her
medical team
that she really wants to carry the
pregnancy as long as possible
out of love
for that unborn child so it's not
someone deciding you know what i
actually don't feel like yeah yeah sure
but yeah
can we explore a few more arguments from
uh that i found persuasive with callum
so
it's interesting that we agree that it's
killing and so we can we can maybe come
back to that part of the conversation
but the other thing that he explained
was that
quite often and look my wife is
currently eight months pregnant yes
right okay so
you know exactly what it's like then to
be eight months pregnant and one of the
things i mean not exactly
i know exactly what she's going through
even if you tell me you're a pregnant
woman i'm not going to believe you
right right exactly well you're very
transphobic but
yeah
so one of the things that i've observed
is that and my wife would would tell you
this herself is that she's gone through
various stages not only physically but
also emotionally and mentally and
psychologically and sometimes she's very
very calm and other times she's a bit
more emotional and a bit all over the
place and this is the process that you
go through and one of the points that
callum made when we interviewed him was
that
if you look at the statistics of how
women feel
if they've had an abortion versus
carrying the baby even if they were
forced to carry the baby through is that
the statistics show callum says that
actually the outcomes are more positive
for women who carry the baby through
than the women who have an abortion
right yeah so in my point being that we
don't always necessarily know what the
right decision is in advance but the
evidence does seem to show that women
seem to benefit
they're more likely to be i mean these
are terrible words
i'm getting myself into awful trouble
here now because it's a really difficult
argument the outcomes are better
statistically speaking for women who
carry the pregnancy through even if they
didn't want to versus the women who have
an abortion that's what he argues yeah
but where do you go i mean that is a
that is
that is a kind of uh i think personally
a slightly wacky
way of looking at it because
once you get into these studies of
better outcomes
you end up going all over the place so i
you know i can tell you the the outcomes
of
uh pregnancies that are conceived to
women in their early 20s
are better than the outcomes of
pregnancies that are conceived by women
later
ages and so on we wouldn't go around
saying it's a really good idea for
everybody to be getting pregnant when
they're in their early 20s and we
shouldn't be letting them get pregnant
in later years because the outcomes
are better
um that really is the road to a very
eugenic society where you're basically
organizing people's behavior on
the thing of outcomes and the problem is
is that
these studies
is very difficult to get comparable
groups
and
i think
that
it
ultimately
comes down to
allowing
people
to make the decision that they think is
the right decision for them
at the time
even though
sometimes
we might look back
and we might think that we would have
made a different decision with hindsight
i mean we do that with all kinds of
things that we do in our lives we do
that with the people we marry or have
children with and so on seemed like a
good idea at the time
not very sure it's the right thing to do
looking
looking back on it that's my husband
you know it's like looking back on
things we're not immune to them now what
i can say as a former
abortion provider
is that
you know and i know that
people who
are very against abortion
tend to demonize us and don't entirely
believe us when we say this
but
the last thing that you want
is to end a pregnancy and for someone to
regret it
you know you really do not want that to
happen
so there's a massive
amount of work that goes on to ensure
that women particularly with these later
procedures
um
are really in a space where they have
considered all of the various options
and they're not making a snap decision
on it because you do not want to be the
doctor
who
is being hauled up in front of the gmc
and accused of
not properly ensuring that women have
consented and been cancelled and so on
and more to the point
you're a decent human being and you
don't want someone to be in a situation
like that so
i think that
you know what i would say to callum
is you can't live people's lives for
them
you have to
treat women like the adults they are you
have to make sure that they
have weighed up all of the options
and they're not making a snap decision
and
then you have to make you have to let
them decide it's a good point uh and
when i said i'm persuaded by his
argument i was not suggesting yeah that
necessarily means we should outlaw all
abortions based on the fact that the
outcomes are better but
is that something that a woman might be
told that you know look you're
considering an abortion here is the
evidence about how women feel
as a result of having an abortion versus
carrying the child through i don't think
that you would well i don't know um
because that wouldn't that be relevant
to tell them well i tell you
so
i think right
and i know that this is
the way that things
go on in
certainly in b-pass clinics
is the
the conversation that you will have with
somebody
that the counselors will have with
someone is very nuanced and
when for example as you quite often do
you get a
younger woman in who's basically saying
actually i really want to have this baby
but my mum will kill me
you're saying actually
she probably won't you know and let's
think about how you might have that
discussion with her
or the person who's saying
you know
i
really want to have this bit i'm i can't
cope with this morning sickness anymore
i can't cope with da da da da you're
talking to them about how they can cope
with it and i think that the
where there's sometimes
an imbalance
in the sort of issues is the
if you take like
the other side it's not really a
two-sided
argument
um
there are
some doctors who are absolutely
against abortion
um
and then there are those of us who are
providing services who who
it's not like you're for abortion
it's the you want women to make the
right choice and where i really respect
callum
is that i think that callum
does really believe
that
abortion is a bad thing for women what i
would say is that
having
run an abortion service for
17 years
there are very very few women who will
come back and basically say
i really wish i hadn't done that
the number of women who
contact us and say
thank you
for
enabling me to
put my life back on track
is huge
hey constantin do you believe every
business needs cyber security to succeed
yes of course because otherwise uncle
vlad will hack the hell out of it
wouldn't that be a gross violation of
international law input in russia we
don't have law well if you don't live in
russia then pocket seam is the company
for you if you have a business that
needs protecting from the unscrupulous
elements of the internet then make sure
to check them out
unscrupulous elements that is no way to
talk about my family
pockets seam also provides free
resources if you follow them on twitter
and linkedin and if you want to keep
costs manageable you can also pay for
their services on credit pocketseem is
the best and most cost effective cyber
defense company in the world i tried
hacking them and all i got was
international sanctions if you want to
protect your company at a reasonable
price then go to pocketscene dot co dot
uk that's p o c k e t
s i e m dot co dot u k and get your
company protected by the best in the
business
if you think about the way that the
statistics work
i hate talking statistics because i'm
rubbisher remembering numbers and some
to be honest do not ask me
tough statistical questions
but if you think that something like
one in three women
in britain will have terminated a
pregnancy at some time during their life
one in three yeah wow
yeah
i know i mean
it's true
one in three women will have terminated
a pregnancy at some time during their
life and the reason why that happens by
the way is because contraception
[Music]
which
looks very effective
on paper and in study is generally isn't
in
[Music]
as effective as you think it'll be in
real life
so
a lot of
women who are
on the pill
or couples using condoms
end up with
unexpected pregnancies
and abortion is often seen as a
you know it it's like you can call it
shutting the gate after the horse has
bolted but fortunately
with pregnancy we're not talking about
bolting horses and you can
put right something that you think is
wrong
but um
you know
there are not a
it is not the case
that there are hundreds of thousands of
women
who are mentally damaged as a result of
making that decision
i think
some women may regret that
as we regret a whole load of things but
mainly it's something that
people can put aside
and then go on
and have children at a time that they
that they wanted 50 you know half of the
women who come to b pass are already
mothers
you know they've already had children
many of the other women that we see will
go on and have children
it's just at that time
it's a problem
do you think that we trivialize the
issue of abortion and
i think it's
banded
around
um
i think that
we
fail to
appreciate
how
women
when they face
that positive pregnancy test
have to weigh up
some
you know like a whole
load of stuff
that is going on in their life it's like
at that point
it really is like
you're a fork in the road
and
if you decide to terminate the pregnancy
then
things go on one track
if you decide to
have the baby
your life goes on another track
and
often for women
it's very nuanced and i'd i'd be the
first person to admit
the
before i became involved in
providing abortion services i thought it
was a much more binary much more simple
decision i thought it was much more
women kind of know you know
um if they're going to have an abortion
or if they
want to have a baby it's pretty clear
one way or the other
and i think now i'd say
that's not so much i think that
for most women there's some gray
in there and
what a lot of women will say
is if circumstances were different
i'd have the baby
now
sometimes
that means that
people will say well what we should do
is work on what you know making better
resources for women to be able to
continue those pregnancies and i'm a
massive believer in that
but often
the things that women want to change
are things that you can't change it's
like i would have the baby
um if i wasn't 16
i would have the baby if my partner
wanted to have the baby
um but how do you change
those things you really can't and so
again it comes back to
weighing it all up
all things considered who is going to be
in the best
position
to
make that decision and it i you know it
has got to be her
but is it is it her though see this is
like yeah this is i'm going to sound
really liberal
but from i was born when my mother had
been 18 for four days yeah
and i wouldn't say i've worked out
perfectly but i've worked out all right
yeah yeah yeah do you see what i'm
saying now
fortunately my my mother my parents made
the decision that they made it at least
fortunately for me maybe not yeah yeah
for me at least right yeah
but
is an 18 year old really the best person
to make that decision like from from a
rights point of view i agree with you
completely every human being has the
right to make the decision for
themselves and make their own mistakes
and pay the price of that everybody does
but when you're talking about something
that involves killing another being and
we've talked about why that's different
i i hear you at least i'm not sure i
agree but i hear you yeah
is a 17 year old or a 16 year old or an
18 year old really the best person to
make that decision really
i i
genuinely
really think they are you know i
know
um
you know i've got a good friend
who
um
is a very
young mom and the dad is very young
as well they're both under 18.
and right but we don't let them vote we
don't let them drink and yet they can
kill another being is that is that what
we're talking about put it another way
right she was able
to
decide
what
she felt
was going to be the best thing
both for her yeah and
for a child that she would give birth to
and she decided with you know her
boyfriend
and with very supportive parents that
that was the best thing now as it
happens
i think that we've seen a
massive hostility
to
young
mothers
and to
teenage pregnancy
over
the last 20 years that i've been working
in in in the fields
you know i think you know there has been
well
i mean it was really under the blair
government where they started this big
um
thing about uh reducing the rate of
teenage pregnancy and it was a little
bit like
it was really bad to get pregnant as a
teenager
but having a baby as a teenager was even
worse than having an abortion and i'm
not sure that that's true for a lot of
young young girls there are some of
these young girls who are perfectly
capable
um as indeed there are lots of
30 year old women who are disastrous
mothers it's not you know it's not a
very age-related thing i think it does
really decide you know it does really
depend a lot on what you want to be
doing
with your life at
one time but
you know um
look let me tell you about one
right and i'm so not making this up
um
when i um
was at b pass one of the things that was
great about the job was that you'd go
and you'd
see one of the clinics and i used to
hang out in the waiting room of the
clinic that's a really good place to
find out where things are going on and i
remember talking to one woman in the
clinic in brixton who was freaking out
because the
list was running late
and she got to go and collect her
toddler from nursery
and she starts explaining to me the
the reason why she's having this
termination
is actually because of her little boy
and the situation is the
um
the she'd split up with her little boy's
dad
she's got a really good relationship
with her little boy's dad and the little
boy and this is the crucial thing the
little boy has got a really good
relationship with his dad she's now
pregnant by a new boyfriend who she
thinks is
great fun for her
but she says unlike
her little boy's dad who is a brilliant
dad she thinks this guy
would be a disastrous father
and she knows that if she has
this baby
it's going to severely disrupt
the relationship that her existing child
has got because it's just going to throw
the whole thing out of kilter and she
said she said to me and i
this you know there are some things that
just stick in your mind and she's saying
i actually told
my current boyfriend if he moved to
australia
i'd probably have this baby but he's not
going to move to australia and i can't
have him in my life
and my little boy's life on an ongoing
basis in the way that it would be if i
had his baby those i mean
talk about the wisdom of solomon
to make these decisions
that those are the kind of tangles
that women's lives are like it's complex
it's difficult
so it
worries me
when
people and you know a lot of the people
on the anti-abortion side
you know are taking
highfalutin moral position that's wrong
this is wrong you know sometimes it
takes the wisdom of solomon to make
these decisions somebody's got to make
it
the woman's pregnant she's either going
to have a baby or she isn't that is very
binary
so who decides you have to let her make
the decision francis before you jump in
can i make one judgment
so
there there is a a voice in my head that
goes
that's somebody who's managing her
relationships by killing somebody else
like do we why is that well you see but
that's what's happening no but i can you
see so the point is is that if you
honestly
believe
in your heart of hearts
that the
embryo
fetus
call it what you will that
human life inside that woman that
doesn't even know it's alive yet
if you think
that has
the moral equivalence
of
us
or even
that woman's
little two-year-olds
then there's no
answer to what you say you're obviously
completely right and there are some
people who genuinely
genuinely believe like that
but i actually think that
most of us
really don't
think that
and the way that i look at her is
[Music]
and i've thought about this i i actually
struggled with infertility for a really
long
time
um and there was a time when frank and i
were told that we would never have a
child
and
had kind of come to terms with that and
then
my son jacob who you know you know kind
of
is conceived and it was
absolutely wonderful and and
i i
value
life in
the the womb
i
it it disturbs me
when people say oh it's just like cancer
or something like you know it's not you
know it isn't really human life
it's obviously human life
but and i value it hugely but i don't
give it as much value
as say that
lady that last
i was just talking about
this her
and there's her son and there's the
existing people in their lives
who are trying to manage stuff so i give
it huge value but not as much value as
that
do you think the reason that the
statistic you quoted one in three women
has an abortion is because of the type
of society that we live in now where sex
is seen as a commodity
it's seen as you know
something that you can do no strings
attached there's going to be no
consequences from it the fact that you
spoke to me or you spoke to us rather
about contraception is that it's not as
effective
as we've been led to believe that this
is something else that i want to explore
do you think that is a result of all of
these things i uh so what i think is
going on at the moment is the
i think that
whether you think it's right or whether
you think it's wrong
[Music]
sex in our minds
is not linked to reproduction
you don't think
when
i'm making no assumptions about well you
clearly said you you've i have had sex
once you have had sex with a woman yes
right okay
even with the woman that you are with on
an ongoing basis
you do not expect every time you have
sex that it's going to result in a child
we have learnt to separate that and i
think that for most people is even more
separate than that they simply
don't expect they expect
to be able to prevent pregnancy and i
think most people
men as well as women would rather
prevent pregnancy but when pregnancy
happens
they
and they haven't wanted it they expect
to be able to
put that situation right and i think
abortion is seen as a backstop
and i think that's just the way it is
um
and that's very different
to
the way that things were
even when you know i was young and
growing up when
um
you know i remember
going on the pill when i was a teenager
and being terrified of the prospect
of getting pregnant absolutely petrified
of it
um and i think that's not the way that
young people
see things now
um
[Music]
whether it's right whether it's wrong
it is
and we have to cope with
that
um
and so
i don't think the abortion is
particularly the problem
i think it's the solution
to a number of various different
problems the the women face
and what's the man's role in all of this
hand because i remember a former partner
was where we had a discussion what would
happen if we had a child and because we
weren't in a position to raise it and
she was like well i just have an
abortion and i remember thinking well
obviously that
i'm for abortion but i was thinking do i
not have a say in this you know it's
it's i mean it's my child as well
at what point did you see i don't know
there'll be people out there going
you're a man
it's important
i think i think it you know it is
important or at least put it like this
it's not unimportant
and um and i think that most men
you know are
deeply interested in
interested at least interested in
whether or not they father uh
whether or not they father a
a a a child
but at the end of the day
um
when it comes down to the
when it comes down to making a hard
decision
as i said right at the beginning of this
discussion it is a woman's body and i
don't think that a man can decide
about that
so i don't think that a man
should ever
actually legally then not in a position
to ever say
whether a woman can or can't have an
abortion regardless of their
relationship to the pregnancy and i
think legally that's right but you know
something when
women come into an abortion clinic
usually the guy's there as well
i mean
they really are it's
usually
a decision that they've made together
because
they're usually in a sexual relationship
you know
and the women who come in on their own
or who
haven't discussed it with the guy
the ones who are not in a relationship
with the guy
um
so yeah you know i think you know men
men matter
in this
but they can't have the deciding vote
and do you remember
pregnancy is not an equal situation no
it's not you know as mcgranny would say
a man can always put his hat on and walk
away
the woman is literally carrying
the consequences
and let's talk about contraception a bit
because you touched on that and that is
something that
i've never heard and certainly doesn't
get told to me by all the adverts etc
etc etc so let's explore that well you
know so
think about it like this
about
half
of the women that are seen at b pass
half of them um
say that they're using a method of
contraception
at the time that they conceived now you
might just say oh well they probably
would wouldn't they
and when it comes to condom use
um
you know i think it probably is the case
the
a fair amount of condom failure is
failure to get it out of the packet and
on to the right body part when you're
having sex
but there are a massive number of women
who come in who are using contraceptive
pills
and using other methods of contraception
that you would expect to be more
reliable and i think that
one of the things is is that
we tend to think about contraception as
being
infallible you know it's just simply not
failing
so
um
you know in tests
um
the contraceptive pill will come up with
being
what is it having a failure rate of
half you know 0.5
half a percent
but even that when you think about it is
if you take it according to those
scientific statistics when the
contraceptive pill is used absolutely
perfectly
that means that one woman
in
200
will become pregnant during a year
well
if you've got three million using the
pill
that is still a lot of women
and if you take it where you think about
the pills effectiveness in real life
where we forget to take it every now and
again or you have a stomach upset or
you know what have you well that's a
failure rate of about four percent so
that's four women in a hundred
who will become pregnant
and
we just
don't
think
about that i mean the point what i think
is ultimately
we need to recognize
that abortion is in a way a form of
birth control
um
and
there are
a range of methods
of stopping
[Music]
having a child
um and
some of them
act
before you
can before you conceive
some of them like
abortion act after you've conceived but
they all at the end of the day wrap up
as being a way of
stopping a child from from being born
and i think if we
you know accept it like that it it
probably it probably helps but
you know as you say women don't expect
contraception to fail men don't expect
contraception to fail so it's hardly
surprising that they end up in a b pass
clinic
when it does well
that's all we get fed by society and
that's certainly certainly not what we
get fed by advertisers
well you know look
think about it like this you know it
wouldn't make for a great advert though
you're only going to get pregnant once
out of 10 times no it wouldn't but you
know
think about it like this
right you you always think your car is
going to start in the morning
and sometimes it's a metaphor
you're getting into that kind of
thing that's going on i i do you know i
i
i passed my driving test
right i passed my driving test i know
the highway code
you know
the
my company as bpas would have been so
delighted when i left and i didn't have
a company car anymore because the number
of times i managed to
back into things getting out of a car
park
you know so
contraception is probably about as
reliable as my driving let's look at it
like that
and would you classify as a morning
after pill as a as an abortion the
morning after pill is definitely a
method of contraception legally
right morally you can go all over the
place with this technically it is a form
of abortion isn't it no because
technically in law
contraception is something
that stops a fertilized egg
from implanting in the womb
abortion is something that ends the
pregnancy and that means
it works after now the point about and
the reason why it is really important to
ram this point home
is that if you're already pregnant and
you take the morning after pill it just
doesn't work
so that's why
there's an important distinction
um although
there are some people who say well hang
on a minute here and i don't know what
carl miller's views were on this or
whether you talked about it but they'll
say well you know there's a period of
time when an egg has been fertilized but
it hasn't implanted in the womb yet and
the morning after pill might
interfere with that
so
if you are really concerned about that
then you might not want to use it but i
think most people are
and certainly legally which is why
abortion in in this country you can only
do it in hospitals or
licensed clinics
um
now you can have the abortion pill at
home but it still has to be
sent out from
licensed premises whereas the morning
after pill you can get in your chemist
because
i'm going to have another go at
the chair because i was thinking about
the example of the brixton that you gave
and you said
well people yes we all accepted the the
it's life but is it the same life as as
the people who are already alive but
we're not talking about killing those
people
we're talking about inconveniencing them
or causing some kind of difficulty in
their lives or a reduction in their
quality of life or their standards of
living or problems with their boyfriend
or whatever
but if we accept that it's a form of
life
yeah
i i i don't i don't see how you can you
can
in any other context
would we ever say well you know what you
know francis is inconveniencing me and
my quality of life's not quite as good
right
yeah you might feel it but i've never
done it that's my point no and i i can
see where you're coming i'm pro-life
when it comes to friends
i'm pro-life when it comes to classes as
well no i think that's you know i think
you know but look there is no
comparable
situation i mean it's really here is
this really the thing
this is not going to get resolved and
that's because you have two conflicting
sets of rights that are very very
important that we hold in very high
regard which is independence and bodily
autonomy on the one hand and your right
to life on the other and these issues
are just physiologically in conflict you
can't detach them from each other we're
always going to be in this situation
there is no right answer
i think that it is actually like that
there is no halfway
house on it but i think
what is an interesting thing here is
that and i don't want to introduce a
huge amount of marital discord
into
your relationship or whatever
but i think that when you say
oh it's just a matter of inconvenience
or it's just a matter of you know and
it's just and all of this weighed up
you might want to talk to someone to a
woman who is eight months pregnant
about what it means
to be pregnant
what pregnancy means
what um
giving birth to a child means
um
and all of the stuff
that goes with it
physically and emotionally
and
think about
whether
how
think about how
reasonable it is
to
say to somebody
who
absolutely
does not
want that to happen to her
to
go through that hold on but that isn't
what we're talking about we're talking
about the example you gave of the woman
in brixton who would quite happily have
had the baby if her boyfriend was in
another country
so we're not talking about someone who
doesn't want to have the baby we're
talking about someone who doesn't want
to have the baby because it
inconveniences them in terms of their
relationships with other people in their
life oh no i think what what i was
hearing from that story and again i
think it comes down to
what goes on with this
is that what i heard
listening to her
was that she has a son who has a very
important relationship with his father
which would be
blown apart
if
another man is introduced
into the mix
being the father of another child
that is introduced into the family
and you're right it's not the
destruction
of
the physicality of life it's not the
stopping of a beating heart
but what she was anticipating was the
end of life as we know it it's not an
inconvenience it's not uh
just things being a bit disrupted
it's the end of her family situation and
that is very often what you hear from
women
is
i cannot cope
with having
this child and they'll often refer to
you know what other people will call a
fetus or an embryo i cannot have
this baby and hold my existing family
together
and
i think that
it's all about context
and it's all about who decides
and you know how you do i mean
if you let me give you another quick
example
uh i have a friend who was raped yeah
and she had the child yeah and she
that massively radicalized her into a
pro-life position yeah and she says it's
not the child's fault
it absolutely isn't it's not the child's
fault it's nothing to so even if this
happened to me and it was awful and and
all of that it's not the child's fault
so i just i
look
i am the last person that wants to tell
women what to do with their body but
with that argument i'm just being honest
with you about my
instinctive reaction
yes it's important for her little boy to
have the relationship with his dad right
but the fact that she is pregnant by
someone else
is not the fault of the baby that she's
carrying and the fact that that
relationship with her former partner may
be badly affected and the child that she
already has may be badly it's not the
fault of the baby that she's carrying
and yet that baby is the one that is
paying the price for what let's be
honest without being judgmental are herd
decisions
yeah but
the thing is is that
somebody
right
somebody
has to make
that moral decision
and live with it
and i think that
you know what i'm saying
is that
i can understand
that you or
and a whole number of other people
might see
that
that
baby inside her
that
does not
even know that it's alive
as bit as having
a value
that should
[Music]
disrupt those lives
and that's
okay i understand where people come from
on that
do you know as i said to you i've
and and be pass now actually
is
running an assisted conception service
for women who can't
become pregnant because it is
thoroughly pro-choice organization
i do not know
whether i would ever have been able to
face having an abortion
myself because
i went through a
very long period of time
when i desperately wanted to be pregnant
and i desperately wanted to have a baby
and i felt that i couldn't do that
now
even now
you know i have
what
great contemporary philosopher ronald
dawkin
um
describes as being a sense of cosmic or
when i look at an embryo it is awesome
literally and to think of ending that
and cutting it off seems
incredibly profound
but you
know i'm not gonna live with the
consequences
of that
she is and and that's why i think we all
look at these things differently
and that's why you know the case that
i'm really trying to make when i'm
writing
is these things are nuanced
and they're difficult and there are
arguments that you can put for and
against and we can discuss it
philosophically
but
somebody's making a decision and
i have seen women in b-pass clinics
who've said
i never thought i would
bring myself to
have an abortion
i've had women who have protested
outside abortion clinics
who when they have faced that line on
the pregnancy test
have
suddenly realized that
this was not going to work for them
at the same time i've had women who
are have been absolutely
100 pro-choice
100 they've been on the marches they
bought the t-shirt they've got the
sticker
and yet when they become pregnant they
found the
they felt an overwhelming
sense of
nurturing
for for that child
and i think in these circumstances
when things are this kind of
personal
the best thing that we can do
is to accept that
there's lots of philosophy going on
and
you know
if people
looking at the podcast want to
you know
read a copy of the book there's a lot of
it in there there's a woman called
judith jarvis thompson we talk about you
know
kind of comparable situations she
did this thing that philosophers do of
constructing this mind experiment of a
violinist who
wakes up and somebody's attached him to
another person like with an artificial
umbilical cord and he's basically saying
look you just have to
put up with them for
oh it's a violinist who's been attached
to somebody who um you just have to you
know put up with them for nine months
but you really need to do this because
they're a world-famous violinist and
they'll die if you don't put up with
this inconvenience
and of course you would never let it
happen
um and she says and that's a born person
who's a famous violinist it's not even
you can't even make the argument that it
has no sense of itself yet
um so you can do all the philosophy
you can do all of the science
but at the end of the day
it's down to a person to make a decision
about something that's going on in their
life
and i think we have to have a load of
these arguments but ultimately they have
to make the decision do you have
sympathy for the pro-life
side of the argument and pro-life people
because
frequently in this country they're
mischaracterized
they're seen as being bigoted
hating women
we all know the the the slurs that get
thrown at them i yeah i
do you know what
i
you know i think
at the moment
there is a profound
intolerance
of the questioning
of
the
um the
the the the
the moral issues and the legal issues
around
abortion and i think that one of the
things that troubles me
is the
um abortion is
now regarded as a
medical procedure that you just kind of
can't take anything other
than um
a kind of almost uh public health
benefit view on
and i think it does miss out the fact
that there are a lot of moral issues
that are around and that we should
constantly be talking about and
debating and i made the point earlier i
know when i was talking to you that
i think that
we have to regard it as a method of
birth control and i think in a society
that wants to
[Music]
allow
people
full control over
who they have
a child with and
when they have a
baby um abortion needs to be seen as a
method of contraception but i don't
think we should ever forget
the points that you're raising about
that there is something
that seems to be fundamentally morally
different
about ending
a life
to not starting
a life and i think we have to keep that
question
debated and thought about because i
actually you know i i think women think
about it
you know i think and and women will say
um you know i'll have an abortion if i
can
have it using that pill and
within the first couple of months but i
wouldn't have an abortion after that so
women are thinking about it we don't we
don't lose anything
by
accepting that
and the the demonization
of people who
seek to question it is
utterly
wrong
and one of the things that i really have
tried to do
when i was writing this book
was to think about the discussions that
i've had
with people who are against
abortion in principle
and try and think about how i deal with
those arguments and
you know yeah you know so yeah that's a
good point so
how
because i i think
we need to i think we need to do that on
a lot of other things as well actually
would have been very helpful if we could
have had some of those discussions about
covid for example
rather than
your provax your anti-vaxx
your pro-choice your anti-choice
we need more of a space where we can
consider and have grown up intelligent
discussions i think
well for that reason it's been a
pleasure having you on the show anne uh
before
we uh
ask our questions for our supporters for
our local supporters that they've
already asked uh and we'll wrap up the
interview uh we've always got uh one
final question for you which is what's
the one thing we're not talking about as
a society that you think we should be
i think what we're not talking about is
the m word the moral
word
the whether something is right
or whether it's wrong
and i think um today being
non-judgmental
is somehow
valorized as
a
um
you know as a value that we should all
accord with
and
um it seemed to be a very bad thing
indeed
ironically to make judgments
about things
and i think we
really need to
find
a way of
framing
what we think is right
and what we think is wrong without the
reference to the
perhaps the old christian ideals that
used to hold things together
um
and
i say that's one of the things that i
really want to tackle and loads of
people said to me don't call it the
moral case
call it ethics call it
something else
and i think we just have to face up to
the fact that
as people we need a moral code
and my
moral code here is not a judgmental one
i'm saying it's absolutely
right
that people should be able to decide
on
matters of conscience for themselves and
on matters of their own bodily integrity
for themselves that's what autonomy is
about and that's what i stand for that
is a fantastic place to end the
interview and if people want to find you
online where is the best place to do
that other than buying the moral case
for abortion if they've got to follow
somebody if they want to do that look me
up on twitter i tweet in my own name
um
that's probably the best place for them
to find me
why is it that a woman is allowed to
forgo the responsibilities of being a
mother either by adopting or aborting
but a man cannot do the same
[Music]
you